[Applaudissements]
je vous explique tout c'est très simple
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir déchets rythme
soit c'est très simple le jeu est très
très très très très très simple si riche
mais les gens ont détruit il va falloir
d'ailleurs on va reculer un peu il va
falloir tirer des boules de neige dans
la tête des chroniques et regardez par
exemple la ja jean michel maire jean
michel maire vous devez vous approcher
et il ya des cadeaux autour d'eux il ya
smartphones que les tablettes une
machine à café une valise un dvd une
barre de son a cédé en fait plus les
cadeaux sont proches de la tête des
chroniqueurs plus le cadeau et vous
d'accord ce sont les filles qui vont
jouer et qui vont lancer les boules et
les garçons qui seront dans l'est dans
les trous d'accord gens me disent année
marie qui veut tirer la première boule
pour voir quel cadeau elle peut gagner
ok dit bravo vous avez le droit à une à
une boule bien après michel adam il faut
pas le toucher à la règle mais alors
faut toucher le cadeau c'est vous tous
et jean michel vous gagnez tous les
cadeaux qu'ils aient tous passés à côté
c'est pas drôle alors vous avez le droit
et le deuxième à aller des prix merci
ne bougez pas de boulot maintenant la
réponse non mais non non c'était cette
annonce alors je sais pas moi l'avocat
d'isabelle morini-bosc voulait tirer sur
qui quel garçon voulait tirer sur qui
avec jean-michel samba bâ vous avez la
chance martin agent ce que je peux pas
tirer fort je vous rappelle je vous
rappelle que si vous tirez sur jean
michel aulas je la sens pas non mais
attends les élèves pouvaient changer
pourrait demander quelqu'un dont il ya
peut-être quelqu'un ou des mémoires
isolé trop même tiré sur moi si vous
voulez un joli joli
non mais pourquoi pour l'instant tout
beau tout chaud dit à la télé pendant un
téléspectateur en ligne s'il vous plaît
qui comme tous les cadeaux merci
d'echery effet que je vise la tête de
jean bricmont c'est vous que vous visez
ou les cadeaux si vous visez la tête de
janvier vous gagnez tous les cadeaux
attention c'est parti
c'est là vraiment qu'il appelle à aller
vous avez droit à une deuxième où les
boules allez attention ça n'a pas de
corps pas dans le coup je vais voter
juste chez bull
je veux juste montrer le boul non mais
c'est quoi pas très fort non je ne le
ferai pas parce que je respecte on me
gêne beaucoup
non mais je peux faire mais parfois non
alors salle elle m'a l'air très dur non
mes chéris ludivine mathieu je pèse
jarry mes plans cul après
il
attendez attendez quand vous entendez
chluski dernière j'ai appris des plans
bah oui non mais ses gammes et la chine
elle ramène des raviolis on lâche ton
slip vrai match qui lui dit ouais ça
faisait tellement beau dit non non pas
d'aller à la tg animaux choisissez qui a
laissé son nom à celui qui veut arrêter
héritage commun à quelqu'un s'il vous
plaît ne se sentent ni les droits à 6
mais si mais si
allô allô allô oui qui inquiète à
l'appareil comment j'en suis arrivée là
salut cristal qui nous appelle nous qui
scelle la fin du sommet d'une petite
fille qui s'appelle dans le
lot-et-garonne ma chérie tu nous
appelles oui c'est quoi casser quoi la
ville tu fais quoi dans la vie ma chérie
j'adore on les vendra aide soignante en
maison de retraite
[Applaudissements]
tu reconnais ligue tu reconnais mais
quid du patient
te marier forcé ma chérie je suis
content louis non avec qui quand il
s'appelle celui-ci s'appelle comment
c'est kristen toi oui et d'entamer sa
peine tout ce talent mais maman
s'appelle cyril avec toi tu savais qu'on
aurait dit que ça lui soit battu lembras
très fort alors la série j'ai envie que
t'es plein de cadeaux pour christelle et
toi donc je souhaite proposer un
smartphone une machine à café une valise
un dvd une barre de son est un cd on
aura cinq boules pour toi tu m'a dit tu
vas choisir la personne que tu vas
mettre là-dedans et la personne qui va
tirer d'accord et c'est paul le meilleur
tireur est le meilleur ambassadeur
apparemment c'est kelly on ne connaît
pas la connais pas assez bien excuser
salon ne connais pas alors max cherry
qui tu prends qui tue mais qui tue mais
là-bas dans l'eau dans le trou
symbole qui tu crois comme si alors tu
peux prendre tout le monde dans la
casbah les notes et toi tu peux prendre
ça les tubes au moins plusieurs benji
mathieu way et j'allais il en faut que
tu comprennes 5 à 5 boules
et qu'ils allaient y a cinq boules
attention si on dit aujourd'hui c'est
benji 5 boules attention 1 2 3 allez
stop
alala tu gagnes rapide et plus facile à
taper l on apprenne plus une tablette
d'une barre de son adn était content que
ma chérie stoppe la balle